yeah walk him to this video I lost lost
some second cm I'm playing against this
Belgian international master to play off
apply to a couple of times but i'm not
sure i tried the ballston Larson Oh 23
yeah that moves under under the Sun ok
take it what now I'll just maybe just
nice to have six the other one should be
a satisfactory the Sun set up hmm no I'm
Bishop g4 probably plays 95 not sure
that I'm that I want that ok this is not
particularly threatening ok let's let's
not think too long him this isn't
brilliant but it's probably ok I can i
play Queen a five of the pre movers a
bit silly
okay yeah let's let's exchange now make
sure that the the bishop is a lot of the
pawn chain yeah I can play Bishop 36 and
give him the two bishops in fact in this
kind of structure it is not so on not so
terrible to give up the two bishops
because of the pawn structure some very
young compact for black and it's hard
for y2 actually I'm open up any lines
very often it's also difficult for for
white to avoid the trade of the dark
squared bishop I'm talking about the
position after Bishop G 696 hd6 if I go
e6 bit should be six it's very tough for
him to keep this Bishop ok jung hwa Kim
let's proceed as planned
yeah I'll go juicy six and tongue and
stay basically it's not done a position
where you can count on any great active
play but it's a very very very resilient
not is spending lots of time this is so
positive yeah it's not easy to learn to
do give rights and some advice okay yeah
just just continue not like widest worse
that's not the case of course but it's
not so easy to to determine how to how
to make any progress this is really not
not so easy okay should i cancel long
yeah one on a check deform and now this
this development here should i play if
five this is a really good question if I
from make the pawn structure completely
symmetrical but you can castle long
yeah it's still probably good when i get
the bishop cool to be six attacking his
pawn he's got the bishop on f3 you would
show I'm not sure is so great I mean
he's got the some pollen of sadness and
as a target just like after was a target
for me and I'm going to go nitey form if
possible okay if I take just how does he
become this way I fly d for you and this
he probably needs to take i'd take f2 so
he needs to take it yeah this is of
course very very dry maybe i can again
well i will play on 444 bit at least
he's got many pawns on dark squares but
then i can play a 3g for them okay it's
really am it's really nothing yeah all
this proved to be a very solid but also
very unexcited yeah sometimes you have
just somewhat dull games okay maybe i
will try a little bit of something here
okay he didn't didn't go for that I
thought maybe he will go G form
okay want to prevent you form I'm not
sure that it's it's really am take a
little bit okay okay there's nothing was
oh maybe yeah of course it's still it's
the lung still very dry
there's some way to make progress always
trying to do something even if there's
nothing really happening there's some
way to to get to the pawn on g-form
probably not young game girl yeah I
didn't really recognize that's a
repetition I've always tried to do a
little bit of something to to to make
make the game interesting or but I think
there's just just nothing happening here
if no way to we didn't of course play
any stupid stuff like I don't know
putting another porn on on f4 or
something I'm placing something on dark
square so yeah just a bit of a dull game
hmm but it shows that this this kind of
structure here or even before you find
this very very solid for black
especially am remarkable is that the
doubled pawns of course more like an
asset than the weakness because they
control good squares and you have the H
valves the H file open so it's really
very salt I didn't even need to play
five but it's probably the cleanest way
to play but it also needs to a very dull
position yeah thanks for watching